hey David you've talked about the
intellectual dark web and so-called free
speech warriors they always say that
their number one priority is to
participate in the battle of ideas and
to debate and to figure out which are
the best ideas but do you believe that
free speech warriors and the
intellectual dark web actually want full
robust debate no they don't next
question no I mean let's flush it out a
little bit okay there is no doubt that
the intellectual dark web and so-called
free speech warriors have built a
following on the idea of we want debate
we don't want to limit speech we want
all speech may be short of a legal
speech to be legal and we want to fight
out the idea battle to figure out which
ideas are the best let's discuss though
whether that's actually what they want I
believe that it is not what they want
and I think that it has become very very
clear because when you look at critiques
of the broader intellectual dark web
movement or the free speech warrior
movement which free speech warrior it's
kind of like a counter to the social
justice warrior I tend to say that those
who attack social justice warriors as an
ad hominem are sort of like the free
speech warrior movement there's a lot of
overlap with the IDW but it's not the
exact same group we know what the term
means though yeah I think we have a
sense I think we know you know who I'm
talking about here one of the broader
trends is when you critique the movement
as not being a movement that actually
wants to figure out the best way to
organize society but they're actually
pushing a particular agenda for example
or that they want debate but they want
arbitrarily narrow debate which they've
already predetermined is okay you very
quickly see that they don't really want
the broadest form of debate where all
ideas are able to be evaluated on the
merits because if you go and critique
the intellectual darkweb movement
darkweb movement either because you find
that it is
a sort of a useful idiot or a conduit to
the furthering of bad and already
debunked ideas you will be immediately
attacked and not because of the argument
you're making if you want some examples
just look at my YouTube clips about the
subject matter when I have pointed out
certain deficiencies in some of the
ideas championed by the intellectual
dark web or some of the arguments being
made by some of the members of the
intellectual dark web the critiques of
me are overwhelmingly ad homonyms and
claims that I'm merely a shill for this
that or the other ideology
those aren't arguments and people who
really want to debate the merits don't
respond in that way now if your response
is going to be well David then debate
some of the ideas with these people
gladly they are all welcome on the
program at any time we've invited Sam
Harris on the program numerous times
even though he has sort of a different
place in the intellectual dark web he
has to date not accepted Ben Shapiro has
been on before and I've invited him to
come back on and so far he is not he has
not agreed to Dave Rubin is welcome back
on the program any time after I actually
engaged with him in the battle of ideas
and we talked about healthcare and
Taxation and so many other things in an
hour-long interview I I think at this
point he may want absolutely nothing to
do with me we used to tax sort of
regularly and I barely heard from him
since and I don't think he wants to be
back on the show he's welcome any time
Jordan Peterson has been on the program
and he's welcome back any time although
it doesn't seem like he wants to be on I
was in touch via Twitter with Brett
Weinstein and I would love to have him
on he is a sort of more left-wing member
of the intellectual dark web
he sent a couple tweets back saying
maybe what would be the format and I
said the format would be I just talked
to you there won't be callers there
won't be other guests it's just you and
I have a conversation never heard back
from him so I am NOT the one here who is
shying away from a discussion and a real
engagement in the battle of ideas they
have no responsibility to me to show up
and debate me in any way but it's an
open invitation and what's at least
clear is that I am very willing to
engage on the ideas specifically and
right now it doesn't seem like they
actually
do that yeah I think when they talk
about the Battle of ideas by and large
of course they're not talking about
specific policies they're just talking
about the importance of having a society
that embraces free speech and that's
what it's all about like when you
actually get into specific policy ideas
with many of them yeah they tend to fall
apart so I would love to see any of
those people come on and you actually
discuss healthcare policy with more guns
or any of those kind of issues and
really frame it that way I think I would
take maybe a half step back because you
very broadly Jenner up the generalized
that they fall apart when you talk about
policy I think that on some of them do
with some policies no question about it
but I think about what we would very
quickly find is that if I sat down with
any of the members of the intellectual
darkweb left right or middle if there
are any in the middle I don't know my
saber but Dave Rubin of course he's in
the middle yeah he's that part of the
new center actually I think we would
very quickly get to the idea that when
both sides are really actually open to a
full and free exchange of ideas it
starts to become evident which ideas are
better pretty quickly and you have to
then say you know we don't actually have
to spend as much time talking about
engaging in the battle of ideas because
you can very quickly start to figure out
which ideas are good and which ideas are
not so good and that's what I
unfortunately don't see that that much
of coming out of this movement send me
your thoughts I'm ready for the ad
hominem I'm ready for people to write in
and say I fundamentally or deliberately
a misunderstanding what these people say
I'm ready for it we've been dealing with
it for more than a year at this point so
have at it and we will talk to you on
today's bonus show